YURI GRINSHTEYN:
Have you ever run
a workload that uses Virtual
Machines in Google Cloud?
And while you're enjoying a cup
of tea during a quick break,
your alerts are firing, the
service is having issues,
and users are really unhappy?
You rush back to your computer
and log into the Cloud Console.
The VMs are still up, and system
resources are seemingly normal.
What can you do to
troubleshoot from here?
Well, you might want to
look at a few things--
whether your AP
processes are running
on the VMs, how much
resources they're consuming,
and whether there are
any errors in the logs.
But as you may remember
from our previous episode,
you need to have the
Ops Agent installed,
running, and
collecting and sending
data to get this kind of
information from your VMs.
If you ever have issues
getting installed,
running, or getting data,
you've come to the right place.
My name is Yuri.
I'm an SRE at Google Cloud.
And today, I'm going to show
you how to troubleshoot the Ops
Agent to make sure you always
have the VM observability
data you need and get back to
that tea before it gets cold.
[LIGHT MUSIC]
Let's start at the beginning
with the installation.
There are two
primary reasons why
you might have trouble
getting the agent installed.
The first reason is
that you're trying
to install it on an
unsupported operating system.
You'll know that's the
case if you see an error
message like this, where
the installer isn't
able to download the
right package for your OS.
The second reason is a
configuration conflict,
specifically with the old
monitoring or logging agents.
In this case, you'll see an
error message like this one.
You can't have both the Ops
Agent and the old agents
installed at the
same time, so you'll
have to uninstall
the old agents first.
Once the agent is
installed, you can
confirm that it's running by
using the system CDL status
command, like this, and looking
for the confirmation messages
that the agent components
are started and running.
If the agent is not running,
you may need to start it.
If it has issues starting,
you may have a conflict
or an invalid configuration.
Let's have a look at
how to start the agent
and sort out startup issues.
If the agent isn't
running for any reason,
you'll see a message
like this, saying
that the service isn't running
when you check its status.
Use the Start command to
try to get it running again.
You might get a
message like this,
saying that either the Cloud
Ops Agent itself or one
of its modules failed to start.
The former usually means you
have an invalid configuration.
Have a look at the documentation
on how to configure the agent
to sort this out.
We'll, of course, link to
it in the episode notes.
If a module can't
start, it's likely
because they can't send
logs or metrics to the API.
Often, this is caused
by invalid credentials,
such as a disabled service
account or an expired key.
Networking issues
and proxy issues,
such as an invalid
proxy configuration,
can also cause this.
Once you've verified that the
agent is installed and running,
you should be getting its
metrics and logs adjusted.
If that's not the case,
you'll need to figure out why.
Generally, you'll
be investigating
three types of issues.
The first has to do
with the agent itself,
the second is with
the sources of data
you're trying to
ingest, and the third
is with sending collected
data to the respective API.
Let's have a look at each.
If the issue you're seeing
has to do with logs,
check to see if the logging
module is running like this.
If the output is anything
other than successful,
you may need to
restart the agent
or validate its configuration.
If the logging
module is running,
the next thing to
check is whether it's
able to read the logs.
One way to check is to use
the local metric endpoint,
like this.
If everything looks good so
far, but you're still not seeing
the logs you
expect, check to see
if the agent is getting any
errors from the logging API.
You can do that in the
logging module log, like this.
You might see permission
errors if the API isn't enabled
in the project, the service
account has been disabled,
doesn't have the
right permissions,
the service account key expired,
or if the agent is using
the VMs default service account,
insufficient scopes on the VM
itself.
You might also be out
of quota for the API.
You'll need to resolve these
to resume log ingestion.
We'll use a similar approach to
troubleshoot the matrix module.
Let's have a look.
You can check the status
of the matrix module
by looking at module
logs and syslog.
If there aren't any
logs, the service
may not be running properly.
Otherwise, you can check
the logs themselves
to see if there are
any issues noted there.
This log is also
where you would check
for any API errors, such as
Permission Denied or quota
issues.
At this point, you
should have everything
you need to sort out agent
issues and never be in the dark
about your VMs running
on Google Cloud.
Thanks so much for
watching today.
Don't forget to like and
subscribe to never miss out
on more "Engineering for
Reliability" with Google Cloud.
See you soon.
[LIGHT MUSIC]